[Musique]
je le disais on va parler de sport avec
vous Michael el midoro vous allez nous
parler notamment des résultats sportifs
on commence tout de suite par l'image de
ce weekend on va prendre la direction du
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour notre image du week-end la
structure 50-oise a accueillie la
troisième étape de Lucie traque
Champions League il y avait du spectacle
dans les tribunes avec plus de 3000
spectateurs mais également sur la piste
avec une victoire de la favorite locale
Mathilde gros elle a pris la tête du
classement du sprint féminin s'imposant
face à la Colombienne Marta Baiona on
l'écoute marche pas sur l'eau quand on
voit le niveau Kia je pense que tout le
monde est fort c'est juste
pour l'instant ça se passe bien pour moi
voilà après peut-être qu'à Londres ce
sera différent mais je pense que c'est
le travail qui continue voilà on
continue à travailler et laisser pareil
pour les filles donc juste profiter des
moments présents et penser au futur
cette Champions League devrait revenir
l'année prochaine au Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines et on continue par
du tennis handisport le comité des
Yvelines basée à Feucherolles organisée
pendant 4 jours le tournoi international
BNP Paris vin will share tornament
c'était le premier tournoi international
de tennis fauteuil programmé dans les
Yvelines il y avait un tableau de 16
joueurs un tableau de 8 jours il y avait
notamment Pauline Déroulède l'une des
joueuses françaises à suivre pendant ce
tournoi et elle s'entraîne dans le 78 au
comité on écoute le bilan des
organisateurs et de Pauline déroulaient
au micro de Grégory cannabis
quand je j'ai su que le comité divine
organisait un premier jour international
pour en faire toute l'année à l'étranger
toujours sympa de pouvoir jouer à la
maison devant un public sur les terrains
où les mêmes terrains où on s'entraîne
toute l'année donc voilà je pense que
c'est réussi pour un premier une
première édition tout le monde tous les
joueurs sont contents au niveau sportif
le niveau alors il y a disparité bien
sûr de niveau mais le niveau global est
relativement élevé et en termes
d'organisation
je pense qu'on peut être fier de notre
organisation puisque on a un retour très
très positif de l'ensemble des
participants
les résultats sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du comité de tennis des
Yvelines et maintenant on va parler du
championnat de fédéral de rugby 2 matchs
et deux victoires pour nous divinois
dans la poule 8 la grosse performance
est à mettre au crédit de plaisir les
plaisirsois se sont imposés 20 à 13 face
à l'heureux dans le choc de cette
division une victoire qui leur permet
d'être premier du classement dans le
second match Versailles à largement
dominé les derniers du classement d'Omo
à domicile le score 57-0 une victoire
qui permet au versaillé d'être à la
septième place la prochaine journée est
programmée le 4 décembre prochain on
continue par du football on va parler de
Versailles Versailles gagne pour la
première de Christ son nouvel entraîneur
sur le banc l'ancien joueur de Lyon à
relancé German Lens l'attaquant vedette
hollandais ça payait puisque Lens
inscrit son premier but sous les
couleurs de Versailles dans les arrêts
de jeux du match face à Villefranche
Beaujolais le score final 2 à 0
Versailles et deuxième du classement
après 13 journées le club est toujours
en course pour bien monté et on continue
par le championnat de National 2 au
stade de Montbauron de Versailles le
Racing Club de France s'est imposé à
deux business sur son terrain dans le
derby face à Poissy dans ce groupe a de
National 2 le Racing a ouvert le score
par heure de vous la Lamb check Tourer
ensuite égalisé pour Poissy c'est Arnold
de vous là qui inscrit un doublé et le
but de la victoire au classement Poissy
et troisième il aura Racing est premier
après 11 journées merci Michael ennemie
Doro pour ses résultats sportifs du
week-end on continue à parler de
football mais cette fois-ci avec un
invité oui avec Jean-Pierre me rayon
l'emblématique président du district des
Yvelines va partir en 2024 du comité des
Yvelines du district des Yvelines
Jean-Pierre Mario vous êtes avec nous
sur ce plateau pourquoi avoir pris cette
décision
j'apprécie cette décision il y a déjà
quelques mois
tout à fait c'est ça c'est-à-dire que je
suis je suis élu jusqu'au le mandat se
termine en juin 202
parce que ce sont des Olympiades mais
j'ai décidé de ne pas me représenter
parce que j'ai été j'ai passé de 12 ans
au sein du comité de direction avec
plusieurs postes secrétaire général
vice-président vice-président délégué
etc et puis ensuite bien je me suis fait
aller en 2008 comme président ça fera en
2024 ça fera 4 mandats de 4 ans
c'est-à-dire 16 ans 10 + 16 ça fait
beaucoup je commence à prendre de l'âge
et puis je pense qu'il faut laisser la
place à d'autres je vais pas faire le
mandat le mandat de trop il faut amener
des des gens pour gérer le district dans
l'avenir et donc c'est une décision
murmure réfléchie juste une chose depuis
que je suis élu président chaque fois
qu'une personne nous a rejoint au sein
du comité que ce soit dans la liste dans
l'hélice que j'ai mené ou une personne
ou des personnes qui fallait remplacer
j'ai toujours prêt des gens qui avaient
au moins 20 ans de moins que moi donc
c'est je suis dans la dans la suite de
ce j'ai prévu et je m'arrête je
m'arrêterai au mois de juin il faut une
autre vision à votre avis c'est
nécessaire d'avoir une autre vision ah
oui il faut il faut avoir une autre
vision personne ne tire remplaçable et
mes collègues vont me trouver un
remplaçant il y a pas de souci ils vont
s'en occuper j'en doute pas ça très bien
se passer ça va vous manquer d'occuper
ce poste oui ça va me manquer mais bon
faut être raisonnable
tout mon temps mais bon je vais pas me
plaindre je l'ai voulu donc tout va bien
non non mais je continuerai d'aller voir
des matchs et puis voilà non mais les
choses sont très bien mais il faut
amener il faut amener des nouvelles
personnes de nouvelles idées une
perception différente des choses des
idées nouvelles je pense que il faut
cela il y a déjà des candidats à votre
succession à côté je n'en sais rien
non pas à ma connaissance mais bon mes
collègues vont sans doute en parler
entre eux etc moi je veulent pas de ça
c'est pas c'est pas mon affaire ils sont
grands ils vont prendre des choses en
main tout va bien et les les clubs
Versailles les clubs Yves lillois pardon
vont prendre le moment venu de la bonne
décision ils auront une liste qui sera
candidates avec un bonheur ou une
meneuse d'ailleurs non non les choses
vont bien se passer vous qui avez de
l'expérience quelle qualité il faut pour
être président du district des Yvelines
de football alors ce qu'il faut déjà
c'est écouter les clubs puisque si un
district c'est parce qu'il y a des clubs
et les clubs se sont eux qui qui
choisissent et qui prennent également
qui qui s'expriment auprès de nous nous
avons notre assemblée générale vendredi
mais les clubs ils seront là d'ailleurs
je les invite tous à être présent et il
faut les écouter faut pas forcément
toujours
faire ce qu'il demande parce que nous
sommes aussi dans un système dans lequel
il y a plein de choses qui nous sont
imposées par la fédération dont nous ne
sommes qu'un organe déconcentré mais il
faut être à l'écoute et puis il faut
écouter aussi les autres membres du
comité de direction je ne fais rien tout
seul je fais tout ça avec le comité de
direction avec le bureau et aucune
décision importante n'est prise par mois
tout seul et ça depuis que je suis
président pour revenir sur votre bilan
de quoi vous êtes le plus fier c'est le
nombre de licenciés à 41600 licenciés
sans 55 clubs dans les Yvelines ce sont
des chiffres qui vous parlent c'est tout
à fait 10000
alors évidemment c'est pas c'est pas mon
action qui a fait ça c'est sur les clubs
qui qui recrutent les licenciers qui
amènent des des garçons et des filles à
faire à pratiquer le football mais on
les a on a essayé toujours de les de les
accompagner d'accompagner les clubs et
de faire en sorte que les choses se
passent le mieux possible avec le dans
la limite de nos moyens bien entendu
mais pour les accompagner parce qu'avant
tout le foot ne fonctionne que par les
clubs nous sommes là que pour les
accompagner et alors votre pire souvenir
à l'inverse du meilleur souvenir est-ce
que vous avez un pire souvenir oh le
pire souvenir je vais dire que c'est
quand tout s'est arrêté il y a en mars
donc vous véritablement là ça a été un
moment très très compliqué pour nous
certes mais surtout pour les clubs et
pour les licenciers vous avez eu peur
que certains clubs ne se relèvent pas
justement de la crise les clubs ont
souffert bien entendu mais ce qui s'est
passé aussi avec la pandémie c'est que
il y a un certain nombre de personnes
des dirigeants des arbitres par exemple
des licenciers enfin des joueurs aussi
qui à cette occasion fait autre chose le
dimanche après-midi et puis qui
continuent à faire autre chose c'est à
dire qu'ils ont trouvé que finalement il
y avait aussi d'autres choses qu'on
pouvait faire le dimanche après-midi
donc on a perdu quelques arbitres on a
perdu quelques dirigeants on a perdu les
joueurs maintenant on est en train de
les rattraper je pense qu'on va cette
année battre notre record du nombre de
licenciés ce dont évidemment on peut on
peut que se réjouir d'avoir un nombre de
licenciés qui augmente tout en sachant
néanmoins que faut avoir à l'esprit moi
je fais toujours le rapport entre le
nombre de licenciés divisé par le nombre
d'arbitres et le nombre de licenciés
divisé par le nombre de dirigeants et
d'éducateurs et plus notre nombre de
licenciés augmentent et bien on
s'aperçoit que le taux d'encadrement et
le taux en arbitrage diminue parce que
ça n'augmente pas malheureusement dans
les mêmes proportions on est en pleine
Coupe du Monde votre avis sur cette
équipe de France et quel est l'impact de
l'équipe de France au niveau local sur
le district des Yvelines
l'équipe de France si elle se comporte
bien et c'est le cas et sur la façon
dont elle se comporte à chaque fois une
une
influence sur l'ensemble des licenciés
on peut le remarquer à chaque fois qu'il
y a une à chaque fois ah oui oui à
chaque fois il y a un boom et là ce que
j'espère c'est qu'ils vont aller plus
loin possible parce que ils ont bien
commencé et c'est très bien en plus le
spectacle et remarquable je veux dire
les matchs qu'on voit à la télévision un
il y a le contenu du match mais il y a
aussi la façon dont ils sont transmis il
y a vraiment de très belles images qui
sont juste avant le coup d'envoi à
chaque but etc vraiment c'est je trouve
que sur le plan spectacle et sur le plan
télévisuel c'est vraiment réussi nous
prévoyez un bout en janvier après la
Coupe du monde parce que c'est un peu
inhabituel par rapport à la Coupe du
monde parce que pour les pour beaucoup
de voire pas pour certaines catégories
la date du 31 janvier est une date
limite au-delà de laquelle on peut plus
participer aux compétitions puisqu'on
aura dépassé la on aura dépassé la
moitié de la saison mais même la façon
dont les choses se passent actuellement
déjà là je suis persuadé que ça donne
envie à des garçons à des filles de
jouer au football
je le rappelle vous serez toujours
président du comité jusqu'en 2024 avant
de laisser votre place on continue cette
page sport à présent Michael midoran on
va parler des Jeux Olympiques exactement
c'était aujourd'hui sur la Tour Eiffel
les organisateurs ont présenté ce lundi
la campagne de billetterie officielle
pour l'événement la première phase
s'ouvrira ce premier décembre et se
déroulera jusqu'au 31 janvier 2023 cela
prend 3 minutes 14 pour s'inscrire et 13
millions de billets seront disponibles
pour les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 on écoute Tony
stanguay le président de Paris 2024 au
micro de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude si
vous voulez acheter un billet Paris 24
c'est très simple d'abord on s'inscrit
sur la plateforme ticket Paris 24.org
entre le 1er décembre et le 31 janvier
ensuite on est tiré au sort et quand on
est tiré au sort on reçoit un mail entre
le 15 février et le 15 mars on peut
accéder directement à la plateforme et
en temps réel on voit les billets qui
restent disponibles on peut les acheter
on peut acheter jusqu'à 30 billets et ça
c'est important parce qu'on peut avec
ses proches sa famille pour acheter
jusqu'à 30 billets et ensuite partager
un grand moment de sport Nicolas dandry
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
nous a rej
oints
féminine de rugby c'était en
Nouvelle-Zélande et justement avec nous
Emilie Boulard bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
participé à cette Coupe du Monde de
féminine de rugby et vous êtes revenu il
y a quelques jours de la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors comment ça se
passe votre votre retour en France on se
remet doucement du décalage horaire déjà
et là c'est les vacances donc on profite
d'un peu de repos en famille avec les
proches avant de repartir pour le
championnat à la fin des vacances quel
bilan vous faites de cette coupe du
monde plutôt satisfaite et
individuellement j'ai eu la chance de
faire l'ensemble des matchs de la
compétition des titulaires sur les sur
les six matchs donc je pense que je
pense que déjà je peux me satisfaire de
ça ça a pas été le cas de tout le monde
et collectivement après bah forcément
pareil assez satisfaite on a réussi à
avoir cette médaille c'est pas
l'objectif initial mais on a réussi à
bien terminer cette compétition et à
parvenir les mains vides c'était le
principal peut-être la montrer ém la
médaille de bronze troisième place
pour pour l'équipe de France
alors une troisième place c'est midi
vous avez été éliminé d'un petit point
de mi-finale par les Black fermes ce
sacré ensuite championne du monde il y a
pas un regret quand même de se dire oh
on a perdu contre les champions du monde
si si il y en a il y en a forcément
surtout quand on voit le scénario du
match mon père a un point je pense c'est
d'autant plus difficile sachant que en
fait à rien c'était soit nous qui
passions soit elle qui passait ça c'est
enfin ça a été positif pour elle et
malheureux pour nous ça a été très
difficile les jours qui ont suivi
énormément de régler regret pardon
énormément de culpabilité de on se
refait toutes nos actions en se disant
bah si j'avais fait ça peut-être que
peut-être que on aurait pu on aurait pu
passer en finale et je pense en plus que
quand on voit qu'on voit la finale et
quand on voit notre notre match à 3e
place qui avait vraiment une opportunité
pour que pour qu'on remporte ce titre
après on n'a pas pu le faire sur cette
Coupe du Monde on essaiera de le faire
sur les sur les prochaines et j'ai pas
d'autres que l'équipe de France arrivera
à avoir ce titre un jour ou l'autre
effondré à la fin à la fin du match
c'était peut-être la pire des fêtes de
votre carrière ah oui clairement c'était
la pire la plus douloureuse et j'ai eu
énormément de culpabilité moi
personnellement à la fin à la fin du
match c'est ça qui était le plus dur à
gérer et voilà je pense que comme j'ai
dit si on avait perdu 40 à 0 ou si on se
fait vraiment si on avait pris vraiment
un gros score ça aurait été différent et
là ce qui était vraiment difficile
c'était consentait que on pouvait on
pouvait l'avoir le scénario du match il
a été il y a eu énormément de suspense
pendant tout le long et on sentait que
chaque action était à l'aide difficile à
gérer etc et jusqu'à la fin on a vu que
ce ça a été un match exceptionnel et ça
c'est ça le départ par cette défaite
mais c'est quand même hyper encourageant
et voilà c'était c'était un grand match
de rugby il nous a pas souri mais il
nous sourira les prochaines fois
j'espère vous avez le sourire
relativise aussi parce que elle a ramené
une coupe une coupe alors on sait que le
rugby c'est un sport collectif mais il y
a des reconnaissances individuelles ça
cette coupe c'est parce que vous avez
été élu meilleur joueuse du match contre
l'Italie du quart de finale contre
l'Italie remporté 39 à 3 et vous avez
notamment fait cette action qu'on va
voir tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
alors 2 minutes de jeu et on relance
déjà de son fond de terrain Émilie
besoin de se rassurer collectivement et
même individuellement on s'était un peu
enfermé offensivement dans dans un jeu
de d'occupation au pied et je pense que
c'est nécessaire que qu'on se libère et
cette action elle a été le fruit de
cette libération donc elle se soldée en
plus par un essai pour Johanna donc
hyper positif et voilà c'était vraiment
du plaisir de de commencer ce match
comme ça et après il a été plutôt bon
pour pour l'ensemble du collectif donc
c'était c'était top les reconnaissances
individuelles c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on peut on peut le dire que vous en
recevez une parce que en 2021 elle a été
élu vous avez été élu meilleur essai du
monde dans le rugby féminin
oui c'était sur mon premier essai
international ma première sélection
j'avais le trophée du plus bel essai et
là du coup le trophée de la joueuse du
match sur sur le quart de finale de la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors justement vous
parlez de cette première sélection c'est
une première sélection c'était en 2021
là maintenant vous avez 19 sélections
vous avez seulement 22 ans et vous avez
commencé le rugby en 2017 c'est c'est
fou c'est une carrière en accélération
de dingue ouais ça a été assez vite tout
s'est vite enchaînés j'ai eu la chance
de faire des mes premières années de
rugby à des sélections soit soit
intercepteur régional etc qui m'ont
amené à aux élections nationales et
après j'ai fait j'ai intérêt le Pôle
France du coup et j'ai fait les
sélections avec le set de développement
et je pense que c'est cette discipline
qui m'a permis de de progresser
rapidement sur tous les aspects du rugby
et qui m'ont ouvert les portes aussi du
15 derrière pour pour devenir
international à 15 vous avez commencé à
Chilly-Mazarin en 2017 et puis là vous
quittez le cas vous prenez votre envol
direction dans le Sud-Ouest exactement
direction toute la région toulousaine je
m'en vais à Blagnac du coup voir
ce qui se fait de mieux je pense dans le
rugby féminin français actuellement j'ai
passé cinq années extraordinaires à
Chili ils m'ont tout appris clairement
on a on avait une équipe incroyable
voilà je pense qu'il était temps de
quitter le bateau de d'aller voir autre
chose de de se confronter à à meilleur
à plus de concurrence etc je pense que
ça me fera que progresser et j'espère
que ça m'ouvrira les portes de d'encore
de nouvelles sélections à l'avenir on
pense déjà au tourne à destination 2023
ou on est plus focalisé sur sur le club
là on va se focaliser dans un premier
temps sur le club c'est c'est tout
nouveau pour moi je vais devoir
apprendre au projet de jeu m'intégrer
dans une nouvelle équipe donc je connais
pas mal quand même mais c'est c'est un
nouveau départ et après les performances
en club feront
un appel pot également pour pour le
financement donc on va d'abord se
concentrer sur les gens
[Musique]